we hit talk of record-breaking
temperatures a lot these days the really
unusual thing about this heatwave though
is the timing it's June not August and
yet the temperatures in some parts of
France are higher than they've ever been
for this time of year if you're here to
do very little and you're on the open
top bus tour of Paris with the Rays and
the breeze then it is all rather nice
we're here for the first time and will
here throughout the weekend which I
heard is supposed to get even hotter so
looking forward to the Hat and I'd say
it's too hot yeah humidity ridiculous
June makes it even more humid than it
would be later in the year because
there's more moisture in the ground and
so it feels a lot hotter than it
actually is and by the weekend it's
going to be hotter still and it's going
to be in the UK as well for the elderly
it really is miserable though and there
are other vulnerable groups to prisoners
in old jails need to be looked after
here in these Parisian cells it is 30
degrees inside there's no cooling system
and they can't open their doors the last
time temperatures were this high it was
2003 and it was August that summer
15,000 people died from illnesses
related to the heat this French
politician spent the morning criticizing
his colleagues who were turning up for a
debate on climate change in cars having
only traveled he claimed a few
kilometers over the border in Belgium
one motorway was partially shut because
the road buckled all the road materials
are less resistant to the heat
predictably there have been forest fires
as well in Spain they destroyed 50,000
acres of land it's here that
temperatures are expected to be the
highest across the continent Catalonian
emergency helicopters struggled with a
blaze which authorities have classed as
among the worst in 20 years Rome must be
one of the most unpleasant places to be
in these sticky temperatures this is
about the only place where it is
bearable signs like this one in Madrid
are never very accurate but they do
demonstrate roughly at least just how
ridiculously hot it is it's very hot and
but we're enjoying it trying to get some
time our skin does really tan and so for
the weekend ahead we'll prepare it's
gonna be hot mark stone Sky News in
Paris
[Music]